It is no delusion that you are on a hike
with your girlfriends
and you came across a bear in real life, like--
In real true life.
We went on a hike,
we went to these mountains.
So you're walking in the woods.
Yeah.
And you're hiking
and you're talking, what happens, act it out with me.
Okay.
I'm walking.
Am I casually walking?
We're not walking like this.
(audience laughing)
We're walking like this.
Oh my God.
And then I'm walking and you're the bear.
And okay, so we see a bear walking.
Now, here's the thing,
there's a brown bear and a black bear
and there's two different ways to react.
And I didn't know which,
I couldn't remember which was which.
Do we go (screaming) and scare the bear or do you do this?
And I forgot which was which, so I did both.
So I kept going like.
(screaming)
The bear took one look at us and was like,
I'm so not interested in you two people and kept going.
But it is the scariest thing in the world,
it's like what I imagine swimming with sharks,
to actually be this close to an animal in the wild.
It's really so terrifying.
So I heard you're a clammer.
Thank you, yes I am.
So that feels safer.
Very proud.
I love clams, I love clams.
Tell me about clamming?
Okay.
It's so meditative to clam.
You use a clam fork,
a rake, and you know, you dig and you dig
and then you're rewarded.
You find these little gems
and I need a clamming partner,
so I brought a gift for you.
Wait, really?
Yes.
Oh, oh God.
Thank you, Daniel.
(audience cheering)
So Ali, will you tell everybody
about your book really quickly?
Yes, goodbye.
(audience laughing)
Tell them why they should read it.
Okay, let's just focus on me.
Hi, welcome to Ali Wentworth in the Allie Show.
So the great thing about clamming is
that you dig into the sand with your hands
or your rake and you pull up these little jewels
and that's why I love clamming
and I actually need a partner.
There we go.
(audience cheering)
By the way, trust the Gorton's fisherman.
No kidding, I love, thank you for that.
I love Gorton.
(audience cheering)
Ali, I have a...
You and me clamming this is so happening.
Well, I think we're gonna have to make--
Look at my clam dance.
We're gonna do a short film about us clamming.
And I have a present for you
because the last time
we surprised Mariska with a birthday cake.
Yeah?
And we wanted to feel, we wanted you to feel good.
And funny enough on the cover of your book,
you're eating none other than the Fudgie the Whale cake.
From Carvel, you know that cake?
(audience cheering)
Oh, thank you, Cat.
Oh my God.
Thank you so much.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I'm in the right outfit
so that I can just motorboat this cake.
You are, why?
By the way, how great is this with the crunch?
It's so good.
I noticed it on the cover of your book
and I was like, oh my God, we gave Mariska this cake,
so we gotta get one for Ali.
And more importantly, I'm so excited to tell everybody
that not only are you guys going home
with a copy of Ali's book, but a $50 gift card to Carvel.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Because everybody needs a little Ali
and a little Fudgie.
Ali Wentworth, Ali's book, Ali's Well That Ends Well.
Oh my tongue is so (mumbles), see?
Ali, take it away.
Tell everybody about your book.
Okay, my book, Ali's Well That Ends Well is available now
wherever books are sold.
(upbeat music)